This restaurant is famous for serving ribs
oh this one is Konro Bakar
Yeah. Konro Bakar
yeah ... OK
photo? ... thank you terima kasih
this drumstick rib is so beautiful
I just got to take a bite out of it immediately
oh that's insane!
oh wow!
Hey everyone its Mark Weins with migrationology.com
in Jakarta, Indonesia
for lunch I am really excited to be at a restaurant
called Sop Konro Karebosi
and this is a restaurant that is well known for serving ribs
in a number of different ways
they are beef ribs
and especially they specialize in food from Makassar
which is in the southern part of the island of Sulawesi
this is a really cool restaurant
nice open-air, very spacious
and you can smell the aroma of the roasted ribs
throughout this entire restaurant
this restaurant is in an area called Kelapa Gading
and this is kind of on the ... what side is this on?
It is on the ... Western ...
North-Western side of Jakarta
and there are a lot of restaurants around here
and this restaurant is famous for serving ribs
and so I got a couple of different versions. Plus some grilled fish
the first dish that I got here is the Konro Bakar
and these are the grilled ribs
and they smell unbelievable!
and after they were finished grilling roasting
they put on a couple of scoops of peanut sauce
I think that is peanut sauce all over these ribs
look at that hand held rib!
this drumstick rib is so beautiful
I just got to take a bite out of it immediately
oh that's insane!
oh wow!
its so tender!
as I just took the first bite
the meat literally just started
sliding right off the bone
look at that!
Oh that is .. that is just wonderful!
Oh man! It's so tender
and fatty. And just insanely fragrant.
You can really really taste the smokiness of the grill on those ribs.
And then that is definitely a peanut sauce,
a little bit sweet,
But really nice and nutty. Great great flavor!
Let me just finish the meat on this bone real fast.
Now that I have this entire chunk of boneless rib on my plate,
I'm gonna mix it in with the rice and I think I will add
a little bit of that um,
Sambal to it
And i'm gonna season the rib meat with a squeeze of lime
to balance off that sweet peanut sauce.
And then i'm also gonna add on some of this Sambal.
It looks like there are chopped up tomatoes in here, and it looks like there are whole, little wedges of lime
As well
Let me add a little bit of that
Oh man!
Oh that is sensational!
The smokiness of that meat
is unbelievably good
And then,
with that sweet peanut sauce and then,
Counter-balanced by that squeeze of lime
And then that, that Sambal
Let me get a taste of that sambal again
I got a bite of that wedge of lime in that bite
That's sharply sour and a little bit bitter
I'm gonna follow that bite with a some of the soup
And I think this is the beef soup with a bunch of shallots in it
That has a bit nutty flavor to it
I think it is a beef soup
It's salty
And those crispy shallots are so fragrant in there
There's so many crispy shallots that it just kinda makes up the bulk of soup
And really oniony fried fragrance to it
In between rib dishes, i'm gonna have some of this fish
and this is a type of Ikan bakar grilled fish
They grilled it over a high fire so you can see those,
Oh, that bone just, the center bone just comes straight off
But yeah, you can see that, black charred, fragrant
Amazingness
On the edges of the fish
Let me take a piece of this.
Not sure what type of fish this is but look at that meat!
There's another Sambal chili sauce here
which was on the table, which i'm gonna add to this fish
This is a little bit of an oily Sambal but,
Oh, this is the type of Sambal I love!
One of the things you can do is just kind of break up the fish,
so that you can remove those bones before you eat it
Alright I think that's good, on with that Sambal
That's a really good fish!
It's kind of a dry fish as opposed to being oily
So it's very lean, and then, Yeah.
It's juicy though at the same time
It's dry but juicy, fantastic! And then with that Sambal
That sambal is like a little bit of a sour, oily chili sauce
And also we could not come here without ordering a plate of the soup Konro
Which is the name of this restaurant it's named after
And these are beef ribs in a soup
But it's served kind of on a soup plate
and
I think they're the same ribs
Just beautiful chunks
Oh, these are two ribs connected, oh fantastic!
And then in a brothy soup, and then just topped with a big handful of crispy fried shallots
Let me,
Let me try to just,
Break this with the,
The spoon and I will just, oh that just literally slides off the bone. That is incredible!
Look at that, just the naked bone is left
And that meat just comes off, so effortlessly
They don't have any, they don't serve you any knives in this restaurant because you don't need them
Oh look at that meat!
The only part that you gotta like, break off is that connecting tissue
And i'm gonna quickly add on a little bit of lime to that
And, okay.
Oh just look at that!
Look at that! That's just effortless!
Effortless! Look at those grains of meat in there
Oh wow!
That is so, unbelievably tender
And so, flavorful with those shallots
And a little bit of a nutty taste as well
In that soup
And then this is some lemon basil I believe
And i'm gonna add that with that lemon basil for this bite
I love the addition of that lemon basil!
That lemon basil is extremely fragrant!
It tastes, very similar to lemon grass
Additionally with just ordering a plain plate of white rice,
Right in the middle of the table, they have communally, on the top here,
These ones are called ketupat, which are the compressed rice cakes
And then on the bottom,
is something called Burasa (rice dumpling)
Which, i'm actually not sure what they are, this'll be my first time
I've had that Ketupat before
But i'm not sure what the Burasa are
So i'm gonna grab on of these
I'm gonna grab one of these
I think that they are wrapped in, yeah, this is banana leaf
And
Oh yeah that's definitely rice
It smells a little bit sweet
Um...
Maybe coconut milk?
Let me break off a piece
And I will dip it into this sauce
I think there's coconut milk in there
And then, it's also salty
The texture is a little bit sticky and mushy
And it tastes like it been, yeah, compressed
Into this little packet
And then maybe steamed in a banana leaf so it has kind of a banana, green fragrance to it
It's really good
The rib meat! This meat is so so good
And...
Actually both of them are really good
I like the grilled one because it has more of a smoky flavor
But the,
The boiled soup one is also really good because it's so tender
And you can really taste those crispy shallots
And I like it with that Sambal as well
Oh and that, I got a little bit more of that lemon basil
Let me add,
That lemon basil on there with that Sambal
It's so tender!
Just finished with those ribs and that fish
That was an excellent meal
I am feeling a little bit sluggish and heavy right now though
That is definitely a meal for meat lovers
After such an incredible, beef ribs meal,
Ying and I have decided to take a walk
This area is home to a lot of cafés and restaurants
So we're gonna walk, just a little ways to an old coffee shop, and I hope it's open
Cause the only thing that I could use right now is a cup of coffee
The walk from the ribs restaurant took only about 10 minutes
And this place is an old style coffee shop, coffee house
And it's actually kind of an entire food court so the coffee shop is at the very front
And then there are a number of food stalls where you can get a number of different things
Cool place though, really nice, area of Jakarta
It's really quiet and really calm, really relaxing, and there are lots of trees in this area as well
I ordered up a, just a black cup of coffee, and a pau
So yeah, he is still preparing coffee in a traditional way
And I think that this coffee shop, from what I read is
a Manado style from Sulawesi
Oh yeah! That is a sharp cup of coffee
But it's really good, it's really...
It's a little bit nutty, and very, black, roasted tasting
And then additionally to go with the cup of coffee I got a pau
Which is a steamed bun and, I got the chicken version so there's chicken on the inside, let me...
Oh that's really hot!
That is freshly steamed, let me break this open
Ooh, that is so, hot and fresh
And, oh you can smell that, I can smell some onions in there,
Smells like caramelized onions and chicken in there
Oh that's good!
Yeah that's like, tastes like caramelized onions
It's a little bit sweet, kind of has that, that char siu kind of flavor
But it's chicken and, mmm,
That tastes good, especially with the bitter coffee
Having a couple cups of black coffee at this classic coffee shop
Is a great way to end the meal that we just had at the rib restaurant
I really like this entire area of Jakarta, it's
Kind of relaxing in comparison to other areas
And,
I love the trees, and I love this coffee shop enviroment here so,
Thank you all for watching this video, please remember to give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed it,
And also remember to click subscribe for more food videos
And I'll see you on the next food video
Terima kasih
Terima kasih!
Captioning by Jorge Rizo